The
other day I did this video about time dilation,
or the idea that time is relative to your
current speed, but that got me to thinking:
there's no such thing as not moving!
You might think you're just sitting there,
watching this video, maybe you're in a car,
on a train or even on an airplane.
But even if you were at home on your couch
trying to be as still as possible, you're
still traveling XXX,XXX miles per SECOND.
EVERY SECOND.
Sit still and think about that for a second…
The question “how fast are we moving?”
is FAR more difficult to answer than I thought
because there are so many moving parts -- literally…
pun intended.
So, let's go through each level of motion
and then add it all up at the end.
Starting small, you're not moving.
Just to keep it simple, you're standing still
on the equator.
As the Earth rotates, the equator is going
the fastest, and the poles are going slowest.
If you were standing right on the north pole,
you'd simply rotate once every day, but on
the equator, you're going about 1,000 miles
per hour (1600km) in a circle, every day.
You don't feel it, for the same reason you
aren't stuck in your seat while a plane is
flying, speed is relative, you only feel it
when it changes.
So anyway, you're already going 1,000 MPH
AS A PERSON.
The Earth is traveling around the sun, once
per year.
It's a trip of 584 million miles (942 M km)
to get the sun back to the exact same point
in the sky.
That means, the whole planet is flying at
66,667 mph (107k kph) AS A PLANET!
Then, zooming out further, we are ALL tied
to the movement of the sun.
The sun is flying through the galaxy with
all of us planets tucked into its gravity.
Scientists determined, the sun is moving toward
other stars at around 45,000 miles per hour
(72,420kph) but we're ALSO moving "up" relative
to our galactic disc at about 15,700 miles
per hour (25.2k kph).
We're not going to fly out of the galaxy,
the gravity of all those other stars is going
to slow us down and pull us back in over the
next 14 million years.
AND since we're about halfway out of the center
of the Milky Way, and as far as we can tell
the galaxy rotates once every 200 to 250 million
years; we're moving approximately 550,000
miles per hour AS A SOLAR SYSTEM.
We're not done yet either!
You, the planet, the solar system and…
The MIlky Way.
Our galaxy is heading toward the Andromeda
galaxy at a pretty good clip.
Numbers vary, a recent 2013 Space.com[a] piece
clocked it at 252,000 miles per hour.
Again, with the three dimensional thinking,
the Milky Way is ALSO moving toward the constellation
Hydra at about 1,342,000 mph (216M kph) and
toward Virgo at like half that.
So overall the Milky Way MIGHT be traveling
as fast as 2,237,000 mph (3.6M kph).
Another sidebar: the further away from YOU
that you get, the more difficult it gets to
measure your speed.
The reason we use constellations and other
galaxies is the same reason we use trees or
mountains here on Earth to gauge distance.
They're large and far enough away that they
become a point of reference.
We can measure our SPEED relative to theirs,
but of course, all the stars and galaxies
in Andromeda -- like a mountain -- are moving,
Andromeda is moving, the stars of the constellation
Hydra -- like the tree -- is moving…
EVERYTHING IS MOVING.
AND the whole universe might be moving.
Yep.
The whole damn thing.
I can get into that if you want!
Lemme know with a like and if we get to 10,000,
we'll come back to it.
It's big, y'all.
Now, to the MATHS!!
Your 1,000 mph, plus Earth's 66,667 mph, plus
our system's 550,000 mph, plus the galaxy's
2,237,000 miles per hour equals = about 2,855,000
miles per hour or about 800 miles every second.
Think about that.
That's mind-boggling, and incredible.
The reason you're not clinging to the ground
in fright is because again, speed is relative.
YOu're not feeling it because we're all on
this supersonic jet together.
Us, and all the stars in the galaxy.
How does all this make you feel?
Small?
Tiny?
Insignificant?!
Or super amazing and important!
There's WAY more to this than this simple
video is going to explore, but if you're like
me, this video gave you some feels.
Express yourself!
Go on!
We'd like to take a moment to thank Subaru
making this big thinking video possible and
for keeping us in motion.
Especially the all-new 2015 Subaru Legacy.
Every sedan has its benefits, but only one
combines them all.
It’s not just a sedan.
It’s a Subaru.
##########
how fast overall
http://www.astrosociety.org/edu/publications/tnl/71/howfast.html
http://www.brainstuffshow.com/blog/good-question-how-fast-are-you-moving-through-the-universe-right-now/
how fast milky way
http://hypertextbook.com/facts/1999/PatriciaKong.shtml
how fast earth
http://www.livescience.com/32294-how-fast-does-earth-move.html
http://www.universetoday.com/26623/how-fast-does-the-earth-rotate/
relative speed
http://ed.ted.com/lessons/how-fast-are-you-moving-right-now-tucker-hiatt
space.com
http://www.space.com/19915-milky-way-galaxy.html
universe expanding
http://map.gsfc.nasa.gov/universe/uni_expansion.html
http://www.space.com/17884-universe-expansion-speed-hubble-constant.html
sun moving
http://solar-center.stanford.edu/FAQ/Qsolsysspeed.html
*B-ROLL VERSION*
In 9/24 Folder
[SUBARU BILLBOARD- Use Trace’s read from
Dnews-091914-Time-Dilation-YT]
(TRACE)
The other day I did this video about time
dilation, or the idea that time is relative
to your current speed, but that got me to
thinking: there's no such thing as not moving!
[[DNEWS OPEN]]
(TRACE)
[[greet and welcome]]
You might think you're just sitting there,
watching this video, maybe you're in a car,
on a train or even on an airplane.
But even if you were
[VO: image 167449679]
at home on your couch trying to be as still
as possible, you're still traveling XXX,XXX
miles per SECOND.
EVERY SECOND.
Sit still and think about that for a second…
The question “how fast are we moving?”
is FAR more difficult to answer than I thought
because there are so many moving parts -- literally…
pun intended.
So, let's go through each level of motion
and then add it all up at the end.
Starting small, you're not moving.
Just to keep it simple, you're standing still
on the equator.
[VO: DA video 80801014_t022]
As the Earth rotates,
*add arrow pointing to the equator*
the equator is going the fastest,
[Cut to @ 0:04]
and the poles are going slowest.
If you were standing right on the north pole,
you'd simply rotate once every day, but on
the equator, you're going about
[TEXT ON SCREEN: 1600 km/hr ]
1,000 miles per hour (1600km) in a circle,
every day.
You don't feel it, for the same reason
[VO: DA video 8088762_013_m @ 0:13]
you aren't stuck in your seat while a plane
is flying, speed is relative, you only feel
it when it changes.
So anyway, you're already going 1,000 MPH
AS A PERSON.
[VO: videoblocks 37007-8]
The Earth is traveling around the sun, once
per year.
It's a trip of
[TEXT ON SCREEN: 942M km]
584 million miles (942 M km) to get the sun
back to the exact same point in the sky.
That means, the whole planet is flying at
[TEXT ON SCREEN: 107,000 kph]
66,667 mph (107k kph) AS A PLANET!
Then, zooming out further, we are ALL tied
to the movement of the sun.
[VO: DA video 808055_033_m @ 0:12]
The sun is flying through the galaxy with
all of us planets tucked into its gravity.
Scientists determined, the sun is moving toward
other stars at around
[TEXT ON SCREEN: 72,420 kph ]
45,000 miles per hour (72,420kph) but we're
ALSO moving "up" relative to our galactic
disc at about 15,700 miles per hour (25.2k
kph).
We're not going to fly out of the galaxy,
the gravity of all those other stars is going
to slow us down and pull us back in over the
next 14 million years.
AND since we're about
[VO: image 453410847]
halfway out of the center of the Milky Way,
and as far as we can tell the galaxy rotates
once every 200 to 250 million years; we're
moving approximately
[TEXT ON SCREEN: 885 kph ]
550,000 miles per hour AS A SOLAR SYSTEM.
We're not done yet either!
You, the planet, the solar system and…
The MIlky Way.
Our galaxy is heading toward
[VO: image 465695791]
the Andromeda galaxy at a pretty good clip.
Numbers vary, a recent 2013 Space.com[b] piece
clocked it at
[TEXT ON SCREEN: 405.5 kph]
252,000 miles per hour.
Again, with the three dimensional thinking,
the Milky Way is ALSO moving toward
[VO: image 503564979]
the constellation Hydra at about
[TEXT ON SCREEN: 216M kph]
1,342,000 mph (216M kph) and toward Virgo
at like half that.
So overall the Milky Way MIGHT be traveling
as fast as
[TEXT ON SCREEN: 3.6M kph]
2,237,000 mph (3.6M kph).
Another sidebar: the further away from YOU
that you get, the more difficult it gets to
measure your speed.
The reason we use constellations and other
galaxies is the same reason we use
[VO: videoblocks utahmountains-082712-1-mov]
trees or mountains here on Earth to gauge
distance.
They're large and far enough away that they
become a point of reference.
We can measure our SPEED relative to theirs,
but of course, all the stars and galaxies
in Andromeda -- like a mountain -- are moving,
Andromeda is moving, the stars of the constellation
Hydra -- like the tree -- is moving…
EVERYTHING IS MOVING.
[VO: videoblocks tmh-030514-galaxy-v1]
AND the whole universe might be moving.
Yep.
The whole damn thing.
I can get into that if you want!
Lemme know with a like and if we get to 10,000,
we'll come back to it.
It's big, y'all.
Now, to the MATHS!!
[FULLSCREEN GRAPHIC: *pop up each line as
he reads it* ]
You 1,000 mph
Earth 66,667 mph
Solar System 550,000 mph
Galaxy 2,237,000 mph
= 2,855,000 mph (800 miles / second)
Your 1,000 mph, plus Earth's 66,667 mph, plus
our system's 550,000 mph, plus the galaxy's
2,237,000 miles per hour equals = about 2,855,000
miles per hour or about 800 miles every second.
Think about that.
That's mind-boggling, and incredible.
The reason you're not clinging to the ground
in fright is because again, speed is relative.
YOu're not feeling it because we're all on
this supersonic jet together.
Us, and all the stars in the galaxy.
How does all this make you feel?
Small?
Tiny?
Insignificant?!
Or super amazing and important!
There's WAY more to this than this simple
video is going to explore, but if you're like
me, this video gave you some feels.
Express yourself!
Go on!
We'd like to take a moment to thank Subaru
making this big thinking video possible and
for keeping us in motion.
[VO: video 2015 SUBARU LEGACY @0:14]
Especially the all-new 2015 Subaru Legacy.
Every sedan has its benefits, but only one
combines them all.
It’s not just a sedan.
It’s a Subaru.
[[YT]] Leave em and sub
[[TT]] Leave em
[[AR]] Go to social
CTA
How Scientists Slowed Down Time
https://www.youtube.com/watch?v=CwkT-4vL3BA
What Is El Niño?
https://www.youtube.com/watch?v=Rjj8qPs6nLc
[a]http://www.space.com/19915-milky-way-galaxy.html
[b]http://www.space.com/19915-milky-way-galaxy.html